what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar and today I'm going to be
talking about some more badass old dudes
from anime in the first video I said I'd
make a second one if it got over 3000
likes and as I'm writing this it already
has over 3400 likes so here I am with
the epic part 2 as promised this time
I'm going to make it more difficult if
we can get 5,000 likes I will start on
part 3 ASAP so if you want to see part 3
make sure to hit that like button and
share this video with your anime loving
friends if you have and be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because if
you don't you'll have no idea when you
videos come out for more anime content
and crucial updates about new anime
movies and seasons make sure to follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar remember this series is not in
any particular order I just talked about
badass old dudes that I think are beyond
awesome as always if you have an old
dude that you want me to cover in a
future installment leave that suggestion
in the comments and upload suggestions
you like I'll include anime spoilers in
this video but I'll try to stay away
from manga spoilers now without further
ado let's jump into it first let's look
at Thor quell the tall from Van land
saga he is considered to be the
strongest living Viking I've been
absolutely loving Vinland saga lately
and that is in part because it's so fun
watching how this over 50 year old
behaves when it comes to battles he's
230 centimetres or seven and a half feet
tall he towers over opponents physically
but also psychologically let's take a
closer look at some of this living
legends best moments so far when he's
introduced as the enemy of Escalades men
he does not come off like you'd expect
an opponent to come off at all he's
cheery and friendly with a bright smile
he waves to his old comrade and says
ahoy it's been a long time floki you're
looking well and quote he responds as if
he just saw an old high-school friend at
the grocery store after many years
rather than an enemy on a deadly
battlefield ask a lad one of my favorite
characters and a legend in his own right
knows that with Thor Kell on the English
side and easy win is no longer a
possibility
the Vikings try in vain to convince Thor
Kell to switch sides they offer him more
money and warned him not to be on the
wrong side of history he just stands
there
looking bored while listening to the
offers interestingly enough Thor quelle
agrees that the English are shockingly
weak lot and that the kingdom is a lost
cause however he wants to be on the
weaker side he wants the challenge it's
much more fun for him to fight against
the stronger Vikings this is the
fascinating thing about Thor quelle most
people would jump at the chance to make
more money and be on the winning side
most people would take the easy win
safety and money but Thor Kell is the
complete opposite of most people the
hard way is the fun way for him then
suddenly he says enough with the
chitchat he lifts a giant boulder that
no man should be able to lift and throws
it at the Vikings the dude is like a
human catapult as the Vikings retreat
temporarily Thor Kell tells floki to ask
King swen doesn't it ever get boring
always being on the winning side when
the Vikings resumed the siege Thor Kell
is loving the battle he has a smile
painted on his face and he's laughing as
he drops sharpen logs at the ships below
Thor Kell even says that he's
disappointed because the Vikings aren't
putting up a better fight when the
obviously skilled Thor Finn enters the
fight
Thor Kell is excited because a strong
opponent could lead to more fun at any
point the English archers could have
killed Thor Fionn but Thor Kell tells
them to stay out of the man-to-man fight
despite the fact that he abandoned the
Vikings side he has his own moral
compass he respects this kids bravery
and he will give him an honorable and
fair fight Thor Fionn immediately
notices that one blow from Thor Kell
would kill him that's how strong he is
he can one-shot a man to death when Thor
Finn managed does got Thor Kell down and
is about to stab him in the face Thor
kale catches him by allowing the knife
to go through his open hand I don't
think a lot of people would even
consider that a possibility but this
boss would he-man just to turn a deadly
attack into his advantage and he's even
smiling as a knife is going straight
through his hand then he lifts the
orphan with one hand and slams him to
the ground he starts throwing around
Thor Finn like a rag doll the Vikings
retreat and Thor Kell is disappointed
that the whole battle is over already
Thor Finn catches him by surprise and
cuts off dork else two fingers some
people might be bothered by losing two
fingers for the rest of their life but
this crazy mofo is excited he smiles and
he slides the knife out of his hand
rather than being mad at Thor Fionn he's
impressed and calls him a warrior he
lets him escape and waves to him with
missing fingers saying he enjoyed the
battle and that they'll finish it for
good next time he goes on to yell after
the Vikings to come back and calls them
miserable cowards he wants them to come
back and fight him as all of his english
subordinates are celebrating victory
later Thor Kell shares his philosophy of
life to Ragnar he says that I quote how
did you fight and how did you die that's
what matters
the stronger the foud the better end
quote I absolutely love this view of
seeing challenges as fun and positive
things we often want things to be so
easy and avoid challenges as much as we
can however a true badass embraces
challenges like Thor Kell and the more
difficult the challenges the better it
is because overcoming it will make you
that much stronger and let you discover
what you're truly capable of you can't
push yourself to the limit against a
weak opponent it's like the awesome
stoic philosopher Seneca once said I
judge you unfortunate because you have
never lived through misfortune you have
passed through life without an opponent
no one can ever know what you are
capable of not even you and quote Thor
Kell and other legends seek out
difficult situations so that they can
find out what they're truly capable of
another stoic philosopher Epictetus
similarly said that the legendary Greek
hero Hercules wasn't great despite his
challenges he was great because of his
challenges if he didn't have to go
through crazy trials like fighting a
Hydra Epictetus suggests that Hercules
would have spent his time sleeping away
in a warm comfortable bed nobody would
respect Hercules if he didn't go through
those challenging situations and prove
himself in the process that is why Thor
kal jumps into danger even though it's
more dangerous than just staying away
from danger Thor akele still does it
because it is more fun and rewarding if
Thor Kell laid on a couch all day
watching friends reruns he would not be
on this list
he's a badass because he chooses to
always do what's uncomfortable rather
than what's easy
Thor Kell goes on to do other unorthodox
things he releases his hostages before a
fight so that his opponents can't use
the
we couldn't fight because of the
hostages excuse when they inevitably
lost the battle you might think that
Thor Kell would let his great power go
to his head and start believing that
he's the greatest of all time however
interesting enough he freely admits that
Thor's Thorin's father was the only man
in the world stronger than him
later Thor Kell says that it's the water
that makes a fish in a battlefield that
makes a warrior he'll do anything to
ensure the war lasts as long as possible
he wishes that the entire world was at
war all the time so he could keep
fighting and having fun obviously war is
a horrible thing that should be avoided
whenever possible but it's still
interesting to see how thorak held views
everything in such a different way from
everyone else you might think that he
would welcome ask Allods men deserting
their leader and joining the English
forces after all that's what Thor Kell
did but when asked lads men do turn
against their leader
Thor Kell kills them why well the
difference is why they switched sides
Thor akele switched sides because he
wanted a bigger challenge while asked
Allods men switched sides because
according to Thor Kell they were cowards
who would flip sides at the first sign
of trouble rather than fight like man
ironically Thor Kell only wants to keep
asking lat and Thor Fionn alive the guys
who do not want to join him I didn't
expect that I have this much to say
about Thor Kell so we should probably
start moving on to the next badass hole
dude but I will just mention the epic
moment where Thor Kells badassery
literally causes the ringleader who
turned people against ask a lot to lose
his mind allthough Raquel did was give
him an axe and told him to fight back
but the idea of fighting Thor kel scared
him so much that he literally passed out
while standing thor kel broke his mind
without lifting a finger that is without
a doubt one of the most badass things
i've ever seen next let's talk about
monkey dee Luffy's grandpa himself
monkey d garp he's 76 years old when
he's introduced and 78 years old after
the time-skip
yet he still kicks but even at that age
while Luffy is a pirate
GARP is known for being a vice admiral
for the Marines the scarp and Luffy are
on opposing sides for the most part
GARP was actually offered the position
of full Admiral many times he's
definitely strong enough but he refused
at every time he's absolutely huge
he's 287 centimeters or about 95 inches
tall
he's been called everything from a hero
of the Marines to a demon and a devil
what I really like about GARP is he
doesn't have the narrow view that
submarines had he believes that a
person's lineage does not determine
their path and that a person isn't
necessarily bad just because he's
labeled a criminal by the authorities he
also has a unique way of treating
children which gives you a sense of his
life philosophy
GARP believes that putting children in
especially harsh conditions makes them
stronger
similarly he's not against hitting his
grandchild with quote unquote fists of
love like Thor Cal GARP clearly sees the
benefits of not taking an easy or
luxurious path in life they say that a
calm sea never made for an experienced
sailor and garb clearly lives his life
with that in mind it's also interesting
how even though his grandson took a
completely opposite path GARP seems to
enjoy and get a kick from learning about
Luffy's exploits however he's torn at
the same time between loyalty to the
Marines and loyalty to his family
ultimately at the Battle of Marine Ford
GARP has to decide if he'll follow
Marine orders and stop Luffy from saving
his adopted grandson ace or if he'll let
Luffy save him he states that Luffy will
only pass him over his dead body but in
the end he can't do it despite the fact
that he wanted Luffy an ace to be
Marines and they chose a different path
he still can't kill his own grandsons
GARP lets himself be punched by Luffy
giving him a chance to save ace the
Fleet Admiral at the time sangoku
comments on how GARP is a father before
a Navy man yet even though everyone
witnessed this they still continue to
use GARP because he's that powerful and
valuable even if he defies direct orders
when the kind who finally kills ace GARP
has to tell San Goku to hold him down
because he will kill a kind who if he
doesn't
despite his tough love it's clear that
GARP really cares about his
grandchildren and you can't help but
respect him for it and have sympathy for
his internal struggle between his marine
duties and his self-imposed familial
duties his badness level only grew when
we found out that he teamed up with
Goldie Roger the Pirate King himself in
the past and fought as an equal in order
to defeat the pirate rocks during the
get this era of raw
the dude was so strong that he had an
entire era named after him including
some of the strongest pirates ever
working under him including white beard
Big Momma Mankato yet GARP managed to
pull off a win with the help of the
pirate king that is probably the most
epic fact about garbs power but besides
his power you have to respect his often
easygoing attitude when he hears that
yonkos AKA emperors of the sea are after
his grandson he thinks it's hilarious
and he smiles even as he admits that if
big mom in Kaido joined forces the
Marines would be in big trouble
this usual easygoing attitude makes what
happen at marine fort all the more
meaningful in conclusion GARP is a
complete badass a living legend and to
top it all off he's even got heart
lastly I want to talk about all night
from my hero academia I just noticed
that all the badass old dudes in this
video are tall AF all might is 220
centimeters or 7 feet and 2 inches tall
all mine is currently 49 years old which
qualifies us an old dude for me because
it is old for most Shonen the main
characters are usually in their teens
so being 40 plus in my opinion qualifies
someone to be on this list all might is
an absolute legend he was the undisputed
strongest man in the world at his prime
he held the rank of number one hero and
he bore the title of the world symbol of
peace what's so impressive about all
mine is that the smite has serious
injuries which caused him to regularly
coughed out tons of blood he still
managed to remain the number one hero
for so long not only that despite all
the pain he was feeling he always had a
big smile on his face so that the
innocent people of the world wouldn't
worry he took all of the fears worries
and doubts of the world and held it on
his shoulders almost every hero student
was inspired by him the most to the
point where it's weird when someone like
kitty Shima talks about being inspired
by crimson riot rather than all might in
the first data book oh my god a 6 out of
5 in every category including power
speed technique intelligence and
cooperativeness he came off as the
perfect hero and this is all the more
admirable because he was in truth so
human and dealt with so much pain behind
the scenes all night is known for going
beyond his limits plus ultra
translates to further beyond in English
it symbolizes moving beyond the edge of
the possible all mites final fight
against all for one embodies this idea
well all for one pushes all my to his
limit to the point where the whole world
sees what all might has been trying to
hide for so long the truth behind his
withered injured body all for one thinks
if he exposes all mice true form to the
world he's one he's destroyed all mites
pride however all mite says it's not his
body that made him dissemble a piece but
his spirit he says that all for one
hasn't stolen away one bit of that all
for one goes on to tell all my the truth
about his sensei and her child all might
after hearing all this fails to maintain
his smile in public yet despite all the
physical and emotional pain that
all-4-one throws his way all might still
refuses to give up he smashes past his
limit he puts his strength into his
right arm as everyone's hopes rest on
his victory all for one prepares the
ultimate queer combination to finish off
the weekend all might but it doesn't
stop him all might keep spying almost on
sheer willpower and spirit and launches
the final United States of smash with it
he made just to do the impossible to
defeat the insanely Opie all-4-one not
only does he win he puts his fists in
the air and remain standing
despite the fact they used so much
energy he uses what he's got left to
retransform into his Opie muscular form
most people would have just fallen down
after winning they would have taken a
much earned rest however he continues to
push himself for the world's sake to
bring peace of mind to them it's always
been about others not himself this is
his final act as the number one hero and
you can definitely say he went out with
the biggest of banks even when he can no
longer maintain his muscular form and
turns back into his weak skinny form
people still can't help but cheer and
think about how cool he is how he's the
complete coolest the fact that all Mike
could do everything he did despite his
shortcomings and weaknesses makes him
all the more badass like the other
characters on this list he pushed
himself and threw himself into the most
difficult situations all Mike kept doing
this until he physically burned himself
out he refused to become a slave to
comfort and
that's why he will go down in anime
history as the badass symbol of peace I
think we can see the parallels in these
badass characters they throw themselves
in challenging situations and as a
result they are remembered as legends
rather than searching for safety and
comfort for themselves they seek other
things that are more important to them
they push themselves to the limit and
sometimes beyond that in the process
they show what they are truly capable of
if you want to be a badass I suggest you
take notes from these legends of anime
obviously they all have their own
shortcomings and aspects that you should
avoid adopting for yourself however
there is something we can learn from
each and every one of these badasses put
yourself in situations that will help
you find out why you're truly capable of
rather than just playing it safe all the
time
no one ever became a legend by playing
it safe and that is it for this video
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video make sure the united
states of smash that like button and
share this video with your anime loving
friends if we can get over 5,000 likes
on this video i will do badass old dudes
in anime part 3 leave your suggestions
for that installment below if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
critical ring that notification valve
because you won't get notified when new
videos come out if you don't for more
anime content and crucial updates follow
us on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar a big thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I'm blown
away by the amount of patience we have
and I'm extremely thankful to each and
every one of you I especially want to
thank our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh baby Rey nothing
but a fan Jason Wilson kings I'll just
$13 beat a qiraji and anatolii kot ski
DJ nathaniel alpha do and angel cruz and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans stephen in grata a
lola naught I'm Matty Mac 239 makoto-kun
seth cooper and the world if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com slash anime
out drawer and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access or
private patron
this chord so check out Pete Charlotte
calm an Emir
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks for
everything and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]